so
let's start with sleep if you're not
getting like
if you're younger if you're in your 20s
i would recommend sleeping
as long as you possibly can
if
you can sleep 10 hours every day i would
make sure that i would get 10 hours
sleep the problem is is that when you're
younger you spend way too much time
doing stupid [ __ ]
robbing your body of sleep and rest and
and sleep is when like you go back a
thousand years they didn't have
distractions like video games and tinder
and motorcycle racing at you know two
o'clock in the morning
you know
there was just none of that stuff it was
it got dark out you felt tired because
you're [ __ ] chasing saber-toothed
tigers all day and skinning [ __ ] it got
dark and you went to sleep and then you
would wake up when the sun rose and you
follow that circadian rhythm right
so
you can't
underestimate the value of sleep and
most of you guys today are sleep
deprived
and i'll tell you something sleep is a
lot harder to fix when you get older
you try going through
stress through work through a divorce
through everything that life throws your
way in your late 30s early 40s you know
for
some guys
and then your sleep starts to get
disturbed and you're lucky to get four
to five hours sleep and that you know
eight or nine that you got when you're
20 looks pretty [ __ ] sweet right so
i'm going to tell you right now do not
underestimate the value of a good
night's sleep a good solid night's sleep
if you guys want to track your sleep i
have this ring that's called an aura
ring uh it's this black one here you see
when i get off my damn knuckles gotten i
can't get it off by the end of the day i
need soap but
it's got three sensors it's o-u-r-a
and
it's i think it's about a 300 purchase
something like that it's it's either 299
or 3.99 i can't remember the latest
generation
um is on sale right now
and it has
the best of the [ __ ] sleep trackers
most sleep trackers suck balls okay this
is the best of the ones that suck balls
basically so it's not perfect but it
gives you a lot of data on
how much sleep you're getting whether
it's rem sleep if it's light sleep if
it's deep restorative sleep uh it tracks
your heartbeat while you're asleep it
tracks this one here has a blood oxygen
monitor but they haven't activated it
yet one of the reasons why i got this
was because i wanted the blood oxygen
monitoring while i was asleep you're
going to have to wait until i do the
software update but the hardware is is
built into it but it gives you enough
sleep data right now
where
it helps you
manage that
if you know what i'm saying so
instead of spending 300 or 400 bucks or
whatever it is that you know you're
spending on dumb [ __ ] right now take it
and get yourself an aura ring and start
tracking your sleep and make sure that
and it just doesn't
track your sleep by the way it also
gives you a uh readiness score which
will give you a good idea of days that
you need to like rest more and days
where you can be more productive
it gives you a lot of other data that's
useful as far as health as well but i
bought it mostly because of the sleep
tracking capability and the [ __ ] that
i've been putting up with sleep
so back to the young man's uh life sleep
i can't emphasize that enough
um it's when your body fixes itself it's
when your muscles repair it's when you
release growth hormone sleep is super
important you're probably not getting
enough i can tell you right now the next
component
when it comes to optimizing testosterone
and
sleep is probably i'm going to say out
of the three with sleep exercise and
nutrition is probably the most important
and it's the easiest one to get
is going to be exercise you need to pick
up heavy [ __ ] and put it down again you
know our bodies were designed to
hike 9 15 miles a day i don't know [ __ ]
it was you know chasing again
saber-toothed tigers you know monitoring
our harem of women and our children make
sure they were safe so nobody was
getting eaten and [ __ ] like that like
you were busy doing physical stuff again
you weren't you know playing video games
all night or you know swiping on tinder
or whatever you were doing real [ __ ]
man [ __ ] so
being like one of the reasons why i got
a standing desk because i got tired of
sitting my ass down i'll probably get a
treadmill underneath
you know like under this thing at some
point too so i can get more steps in but
like sitting down and being like
stationary for long periods of time is
not good for your [ __ ] health man
exercise go out get a gym membership
pick up heavy [ __ ] put it down you'll
feel better about yourself you'll
produce more testosterone if you want to
just like go in and and like get healthy
levels of testosterone just do heavy
compound movements bench press squats
dead lifts stuff like that
um do it minimum three days a week make
sure you get an adequate rest in between
your uh exercise routines there's lots
of [ __ ] on the internet about how to
body build and how to lift heavy weights
and how to do heavy compound movements
and optimize all that stuff go find it
so that's the second component when
you're a young man the third is going to
be your nutrition and some people right
now are going well you got to talk about
no fap and all that [ __ ] i'm not talking
about that [ __ ] okay i'll i'll touch
on it briefly but nutrition is going to
be the third one and
i'm gonna put that one last i'm just
gonna be honest with you because my
experience like
my experience in my 20s myself and my
friends is you could literally
go to the gym
go to mcdonald's and pick up six [ __ ]
big macs
when they were 99 cents you could get
like
six dollars worth of big macs smash
those things back
go home roll up a fat j smoke it listen
to some pink floyd and then smash bag
back bags of doritos and that was your
nutrition and you could still look
really good
so
your body has a way of adapting to
whatever you put into it i'm not saying
put [ __ ] in your body
uh i eat very clean today but had i done
that back in my 20s i would have
probably been in better shape today you
know if i'm being honest so
nutrition does play a role but sleep and
exercise sleep number one exercise
number two nutrition number three that's
what i got there
um for a young guy
you're probably going to want to
i mean
if there's a handful of supplements that
i could advise to young men
make sure you get an adequate protein so
if you have to supplement with protein
do it
you're probably going to be deficient
everybody's going to be deficient in
vitamin d if you're caucasian and you
live north or south of the tropics so
the tropic of capricorn and the tropic
of cancer ones in the northern
hemisphere one's in the southern
hemisphere you guys took geography right
if you live north of the tropics or
south of the tropics below the equator
you're going to be deficient in vitamin
d vitamin d it's called vitamin d but
today especially in hormone therapy
clinics they're not calling it a vitamin
they're calling it basically a hormone
because it's that important vitamin d is
very is incredibly important in the
production of testosterone and if you're
deficient in vitamin d you're not going
to be able to produce testosterone
bottom line
again if you're sitting inside all day
you work an indoor job you don't get
sunlight you're not getting sunlight in
the winter time you're definitely going
to be well deficient on vitamin d so you
need to supplement with that i'm going
to talk about supplements in a minute
those would be the main ones if you're a
young guy and especially budget
conscious again like i remember like
dude like i remember being you know
being in my 20s going i want to get big
i want to
look impressive i want to look like
arnold
never got there um
and i need to eat calories so i'd go out
and like smash back you know the six big
macs you know for for for a meal like
you you had to innovate when you were
young and you didn't have a lot of money
i remember going out for like meals and
[ __ ]
my buddy had this girlfriend that he had
for a while and you know he'd always
bring her out and [ __ ] we'd go and eat
and she didn't eat much and it's like
you know we'd be sitting there at like
22 23 and i'm done eating i've smashed
back my food he has and she's still
[ __ ] pecking away at like a bird and
i'm like you gonna eat all that so it
was like an ongoing joke whenever we
went out anywhere it's like rich would
always say you're gonna eat all that
because i was always looking for the
extra calories right didn't it you know
like the nutrition part matters
anyway those are the three main things
um let me see what we got here in the
chat i see people are talking about
vitamins and stuff yeah here let me get
to uh vitamins and supplements and by
the way guys testosterone is
manufactured from cholesterol okay so
one of the big mistakes that i made in
my 20s is usually i
like eggs didn't really cost that much
back then they still don't cost that
much today it's a very good source of
protein and i used to hard boil about a
half dozen eggs so i'd hard boil about
six eggs get them out of the shells and
i would basically cut them in half
and then squeeze the um
yellow yolk part out and never even eat
it because i was told at that time that
you want to only eat egg whites because
the yellows contained
fats and cholesterol and it wasn't good
for your heart and all that kind of
[ __ ] but the truth of matter is you
need cholesterol and a very good source
of healthy cholesterol is actually egg
yolks so
eat eggs for breakfast you know i used
to eat a lot of egg salad sandwiches uh
tuna sandwiches you know is a decent
source of protein as well the problem
with fish though especially canned fish
is you end up with like
uh fine levels of uh metals mercury is
probably the main one that you got to be
careful of um you know which you can
check with blood labs by the way but
yeah uh here let me throw up some
supplements over here but yeah
cholesterol is another big one too make
sure you're getting sufficient
cholesterol don't throw away the yellows
of the eggs eat them uh make sure you're
getting cholesterol daily because
testosterone is made from cholesterol
um there's there's good cholesterol is
bad cholesterol and your doctor can
explain all that [ __ ] to you with your
blood labs i'm not a doctor i'm not
giving you medical medical advice
um so here are the
uh add to supps
so
the unplugged alpha do i have a banner
for that
no i don't it doesn't look like i do um
so the unplugged alpha supplement line
can be found i'm just going to copy and
paste this in the live chat
and the testosterone support products
are organized by filters so all you have
to do
is hit this drop down and then filter
down whatever it is that you're looking
for
you don't just want to take the alpha t
product okay
it's synergistic with vitamin d and k
and zinc
let me
open up the labels here because this is
always helpful
but you want about 10 000 iu of vitamin
d per day and it has to have a
corresponding dosage of vitamin k
the thing with vitamin d is if you just
take vitamin d caplets or spray and it
doesn't have vitamin k in it it
calcifies in your arteries and it's
going to cause problems for you it's
going to cause problems with circulation
you could end up with heart disease um
blood needs to flow into your johnson if
you have plaque buildup and calcium
buildup in your arteries you're not
going to get a heart on properly so
vitamin k
you need to take a vitamin d product
with a vitamin k infused into it and
there's a reason why these two exist and
this product the alpha dk product it's
not expensive it's 34 bucks all you need
is two of these pills because they're
5000 iu each
you'd probably need about 10 000 iu's a
day especially if you live north or
south of the tropics
again you can and you should verify this
with blood labs you'll also see over
here that it says percentage of daily
value is 625 percent because the
government recommended daily value is so
obscurely below where it needs to be if
you like honestly if you came out of
this pandemic and you're still taking
medical advice from the government you
need to check your head right because
there's a whole bunch of lies and
[ __ ] there that you've been paying
attention to um
super super
you know super super important uh
complex there is a vitamin dk get it uh
the other one is zinc
um
one of the
most important
minerals that you're going to need
there's a lot there's lots of micro
minerals but zinc is by far
the most important when it comes to
testosterone production you can get
loads of zinc from things like shellfish
so oysters and mussels
um
go out you know once a week if you don't
like making them go out to an oyster
place or go out to a muscle place and
get some oysters and mussels like
whenever you have the opportunity eat
some of that [ __ ] i understand there's
some people that are
you know have an aversion towards
shellfish
fine you know find a substitute but
nothing has
the levels of zinc as shellfish so eat
it don't eat it i don't give a [ __ ]
um supplement facts for alpha zig
product zinc isn't that expensive it's a
relatively cheap supplement you should
be taking it if you're a young guy
okay it's like less than 19 bucks here
on my website so
you you're gonna want somewhere between
30 to 50 to 60 milligrams of zinc
um the serving size for one capsule
gives you 30.
i take two of these a day so i'm getting
60 milligrams i'm not small though like
i'm i'm six two and a half two hundred
and
eighteen ish pounds right now
something like that um it also has
taurine and malic acid and a few other
uh
vitamins and minerals in it as well but
the alpha zinc product has a very high
quality zinc
um
definitely add it to your protocol
and then the final one of course is
alpha t which is the main testosterone
support product
which has uh tribulus uh chryson which
is an ai essentially
it's probably the most effective
aromatize inhibitor aside from dim and
cdg
um you you learn a lot about these
topics when you get into therapeutic
testosterone because you have to make
sure you're managing estrogen
uh dr anthony j's book the um it's
called s regeneration i did a podcast
interview with him on my channel search
for it just search rich cooper anthony j
ester generation and watch that because
he explains all the environmental
sources of estrogen that you're getting
through things like tap water
food packaged in
plastic containers soy is a big source
of it
i learned that licorice tea is a source
of environmental estrogen so all these
things you keep piling them all in your
body and they build up over time
and you become more estrogen dominant
it's one of the reasons why you see a
lot of guys today walking around with
female breast tissue
and storing so much fat on their body is
because they're generally estrogen
dominant and one of the things that you
get from having healthy levels of
testosterone is you generally have
healthy levels of body fat as well too
it's not often that you'll that you'll
find a guy naturally that's high tea
with loads of body fat
generally the fatter you get the lower
your testosterone levels go so it's like
a double-edged sword i mean if you're
three or four hundred pounds and you're
obese
and you wanna optimize your testosterone
but you're having a hard time with it
because now you've created this complex
problem of [ __ ] in your body because
of some stupid choices in your life
bad sleep lack of exercise sedentary
lifestyle shitty food you know you stack
all those things together and then
you're kind of [ __ ] and it's like how
do i get rid of the body fat and it's
now you've got an estrogen dominant
problem and then you compound that with
bad food with water i've talked about
this before but
a lot of women today are are on birth
control they go to the bathroom they
urinate hormones come out of their body
including what is in the female birth
control which is an estrogen it goes
into the water system they clean it out
of things like toilet paper feces
anything else you flush down the toilet
and then they
probably apply some uv to it or
something and then they send it back
into the water system and then we drink
it again and
the problem with that is that
you can remove particles from water but
you can't remove hormones hormones
aren't particulates um they're hormones
so
toilet paper feces they can filter all
that [ __ ] out they can clean it out they
can sanitize the water it's good to go
you can drink it but there's estrogen in
your tap water
um you need a five-stage reverse osmosis
water filtration system if you're
drinking tap water try to drink water
that's from a filtered source britas
don't do it they don't [ __ ] capture
the hormones it's only going to be a
system
it's like these under counter systems
they're called five stage reverse
osmosis they're usually
700 of a thousand bucks depending on the
complexity of the system but it just
takes water out of your tap runs it
through a proper filtration system and
then you can drink that
drink bottled water drink container
water whatever it happens to be but stay
away from tap water whenever possible
distilled water is good too
i do water treatment plant work and rich
is speaking the truth yes
i do not lie to you guys i know there's
people out there that lie to you
you always get it uh straight and narrow
for me
so again this uh testosterone
support product alpha t
so it's got tribulus which uh is proven
to improve testosterone levels chryson
which is going to reduce your estrogen
levels tonguet ali which is an effective
testosterone booster dim
which is an extract from things like
broccoli cauliflower kale that also
naturally
reduces your testosterone sorry not your
testosterone your estrogen levels
horny goat weed ginkgo extract and boron
all essential for testosterone support i
would recommend getting all three of
these
okay uh just hit it add it to the cart
go to this go to the subscribe and save
option get it delivered every 30 days or
you know whatever frequency it is that
you want and make sure you're
supplementing with things that support
your testosterone production
uh vitamin dk and a zinc product all
three of these and again that'll be
pinned in the
description below and the top comment
i also run an ad in the middle of every
video as well which talks about it as
well but just go to the
unpluggedalpha.com
okay so that's your supplements hey guys
i really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you